abone ol
bu
Merhaba
Merhabalar adım Emir elidemir bir içerik
üreticisi bir şefim
Evet Ee Peki ben kimim
ben 27 yaşındayım İzmirliyim Diş Hekimi
bir baba aynı zamanda sporcu ve gazeteci
Bir annenin tek çocuğuyum
bu
ilkokulda ya çok yaramaz ya afacan bir
çocuktum gerçekten hiç bir ailenin
evladı olmasını istemeyeceği tipte
afacanlık dan bahsediyorum yani Annem ve
babam hiç okuldan çıkmazlar the Annem
Veli toplantılarında ne ve geldiğinde
Bağlar
dışı çok hareketliydi mşü psikologların
da yardımıyla bu hareketi bu enerjiyi
sporu aktarmamız gerektiğini söylediler
bize Ve öyle de yaptık atletizme
başladım
iyi doldu atletizmde il il şampiyonluğu
yaşadım ondan sonra Türkiye
Şampiyonasına gittim Ondan sonra da
baskete
baskete geçtim basketbolda da
İzmir'in köklü kulüplerinden altyapıda
basketbol oynamaya başladım ama başına
talihsiz bir olay geldi ve
Aslında büyük bir problem değildi bu ama
hemen Vazgeçtim basketbol şu anda
bıraktım hayatımdaki en büyük
pişmanlıklarından biridir Bu ilk
vazgeçip şimdi hayatındaki Basketboldan
Vazgeçtim
baz Basketboldan vazgeçtikten sonra
bana okulumu ağırlık vermek istedim
Babam Ve amcam sağlıklı İkisi de doktor
ve İzmir'de borno Anadolu Lisesi vardı
ikisi de oradan mezun ve bu bir aile
geleneği gibidir bizim için o listeye
girmek ve o benim için büyük bir hedefti
çok ders çalıştım ve o listeye girdim
liseye girdikten sonra o Afacan Emir
geri çıktı içimdeki o disiplinsiz
ilkokuldaki Emir spordan uzaklaşma
birlikte geri çıktı kendini gösterdi ve
dört sene boyunca lisede başarısız olmak
için ne gerekiyorsa yaptım ve derslerimi
tamamen umursamadım
Evet Ee ama aynı dönemde yemek aşkımı da
fark ettim yemekli olan ilk buluşma bu
dönemlere geliyor
annemle Evde oturup yabancı şeflerin
televizyon kanalında yaptığı hareketleri
izledik Ben de boşu bu şekilde kesmek
istiyorum Ben de bu şey böyle kullanmak
istiyorum Erdim anneme evde birlikte
yemeklerden geldik hep
ondan sonra bir Ali senin son döneminde
artık bir tercih yapmam gerekiyordu
üniversite sınavı yaklaşıyor ve ben ne
yapacağımı hala Emin değildim bir baba
mesleği olarak diş doktorları istiyorum
Diş hekimliğini ve bunun için çalıştım
Ama tabii bu anlattığım gibi dört sene
boş geçirdiğim için o dört sene bana
yetmemişti ve hayatından bir sene
kaybederek tekrar çalışmak durumunda
kaldım Üniversite sınavına hazırlanmak
için bir sene daha çalıştım ve sınav
sonucunda diş doktorluğu kazana
biliyorduk yani ki de biliyordum
üniversitede eğitim alabiliyordum
ama kendinden emin değilim Bu yüzden bu
Bu bir konuşma yaptım babam ya annemle
de dedim ki ben ne yapayım sence Baba ne
yapmam gerekiyor Babam bana dedi ki
Bence diş doktorluğu senin hayalindeki
iş değil gerçekten hayalindeki işi
yapmam gerekiyor annem de tamam diş
doktorluğunun Hiç ağzından bile
çıkarmadan benim bir şey olmamı
istiyordu her zaman gastronomi okumaya
Çünkü ailem de bana en yakın İnsanoğlu
yemek aşkımı en iyi bilen insan oydu
O yüzden Şef olmam da çok ısrarcı ydı
ben de o zaman için Radikal kararı Çünkü
Sevr anda hiç gastronomi ile ilgilenen
hiçbir insan yoktur isem de sözel
öğrenci bile yoktu tek Seçen benim
rasyonelmi gastronomi seçtim ve adım
attım en büyük adamın buydu biraz ya çok
fazla sonunu düşünmeden sadece aşçı
olmak için garsonun bölümüne girdim bu
Gastronomi bölümü ne girdikten sonra
Ne
bileyim bakalım ne oldu yine dersiniz
lashton veya ilk mutfak dersinden kaldım
okulda yeteri kadar umursamıyorum
sanırım hiçbir şey veya yeter yorgun
olgunlukta değildim
ama bu sefer kendime bir söz verdim
Dedim ki
sporda
karşına ben gel çıktı vazgeçtin
derslerinde umursamadın engellerden
Vazgeçtim devam etmedin belki istediğin
kadar yüksek başarılara sahip olamadın
Bu sefer başka bir şansın yok Bu Senin
mesleğin artık bunu seçtim ve en iyisi
olmak zorundasın Bu yüzden
yurtdışındaki en iyi restoranları buldum
Michelin yıldızlı restoranları yaklaşık
yüz tanesine mail attım mailimin içeriği
de şuydu
Ben size bir şey veremem herhangi bir
maddi Beklentim de yok Tek istediğim şey
sizden almak alabildiğim kadar çok
tecrübe kazanmak
5-6 tanesi geri döndü ve kendimi Holland
abone ol
Ama bu dönem benim için en zor dönemde
hayatının en zor dönemini Çünkü
gastronomi seçtiğimde ve şef olmak
istediğim de aslında için bu kadar zor
bir noktaya gelebileceğini tahmin
etmemiştim günde 18 saat çalışıyordum
Ellerime baktım da ellerim şekil
değiştirmiştir gece ve ağlayacak gibi
oluyorum Ellerimi gördüğünde ve insanlar
çok acımasız the Üzerime çok büyük bir
baskı vardı işi bilmediğim için ve
aslında Oraya ait olmadığım için o
zamanlar çok büyük bir baskı altındaydım
vazgeçmedim Vazgeçmediğim için çok
gelişe bildim bu üç aylık dönem sonunda
ve
bittiğinde artık kendim bir mutfak
elemanı olarak görebiliyorum Eskiden
Belki de utanırdım bir sesim demeye o
kadar uzaktın konuyu
bu üç aylık serüveninden sonra zaten
devamı geldi Bir sene sonra da Fransa'da
üç ay geçirdim yine Michelin yıldızlı
Restoran da onlarla da çalışmak çok
zorlayıcı da aynı ve kültürlerle
görüyorsunuz ve dilini konuşmuyorsunuz O
yüzden daha da fazla zorluyor sizi ama
zorlanmaya alıştırdım kendimi ve bundan
hoşnut kalmaya başladım Şu
a ve e üniversitem bunları üniversite
zamanı yaz aylarında yapıyorum
üniversite bittikten sonra niye orta
gitme kararı aldım Çünkü niye ortadaki
restoranların iyi olduğunu biliyordum ve
beni geliştirecek lerinden emindim O
yüzden sevimli yolladım beni yoksa
çalışmaya başladım
zorlu bir mutfakta
Michelin yıldızlı kazanmaya aday bir
rakı mutfakta şefleri çok iyiydi Venus
olacakları biliyordum Bir sene boyunca
pozisyon için mücadele ettim ve kazandım
pozisyonumu bu sene sonunda da bir
Michelin yıldızlı kazandı restoranı
Zaten ben oradayken
bu Belki başarabilirim çok fazla şey
olduğunu hissediyordum Amerika'da da
zaman geçirirken ama Vatanımı da
özlemiştim Türkiye'de yapabileceklerimi
görmek istiyordum O yüzden geri dön dön
Türkiye
Türkiye'de iki üç farklı restoranda
çalıştım
Evet Ee belki bana denk gelmedi o sırada
aradığım disiplini bulamadım aradığım
zor lan yeteri kadar zorlanmıyor
hissediyordum kendimi o yüzden ve aynı
zamanda da farklı kültürler görmek her
zaman Hoşuma gittiği için Kanada'ya iş
başvurusunda bulunun
Tam o sırada
pandemi patlak verdi maalesef ve
biliyorsunuz ki hizmet sektörü bundan en
çok etkilenen
sektörlerden biridir ve soruların hepsi
kapandı Ben de evet sıkıldım herkes gibi
Herkesin yaptığı gibi Hatta evi
düzenlemeye başladım işte çalışma
odasını düzenliyorum ama ne yapıyorum
ben diye düşünüyorum ve bu sayede sosyal
medya ilk adımımı attım insanlara
birşeyler öğretmek istiyorum Yemek
Bildiklerimi insanlara geçirmek
istiyorum bu yüzden sosyal medya adım
attım video çekmeye başladım sosyal
mecraları bir baktım ki bir restoranda
şef olarak çalıştığımda yemeğimi Belki
bir günde 30-40 kişi yiyor ama sosyal
medyada istediklerimi yüzlerce binlerce
insana Belki de milyonlarca insanı
aktara biliyoruz vermek istediklerini bu
hoşuma gitti bir şerit için yemeğini
birine tattırmak ve karşılığında Ondaki
mutluluk duygusu aynı zamanda senin
içinde mutluluktur sosyal medyada bu
hissin aynısını veya çok benzerini
yaşadığımı fark ettim o yüzden bu çok
hoşuma gitti
ve ondan sonra da zaten ben Master
çekelim Master Chef yarışma programını
master.sef benim için çok güzel geçti
aldığım referanslar güzel çıktığında çok
mutluydum insanların bana olan
tepkilerinden dolayı
benim için başarılı bir sonuçtu 3. oldum
kazanmak istiyordum ama maalesef 3.
oldum girdiğim bir şey illaki kazanmak
istiyorum çünkü
bu mastercheften sonra ama önümde İki
Yol vardı kanada'daki iş başvurumu hala
duruyordu ve beni istiyorlardı gitmem
gerekiyordu ya da video çekip daha fazla
insana ulaşmak isteyecektim hangisini
yapacaktım ailem arkadaşlarına bir
toplantı yaptım Bana hangisini
istediğimi sordular yine
ben de Ben mutfakta yaklaşık 1000 saat
soğan doğradım
bana bir kürdan verdiler ve mutlu 18
saatlik çalışmanın üstüne kürdanla
mutfağının en ücra köşelerini temizledim
ve bunu Haftanın altı günü yaptım
binlerce saat tek başıma Bana kendimi
karides ayıplı yokken buldum ve hiçbir
zaman pes etmedim Bu sayede mutfakta
başarılı oldum biliyordum ki içerik
üreticisi olarak Eğer binlerce saat
video izlersem nasıl çekildiğini
anlarsan ve binlerce farklı tarih
çekersen bunda da başarılı olacaksın
kendime Oğuz Güven Kendine özgüveni
hisse ya o yüzden içerik üreticisi
olmaya karar verdim bir yarışmadan
çıktıktan sonra artık daha fazla
tanıyordum ve insanlara ulaşabilirim
bunda da başarılı oldum çıktıktan sonra
yaklaşık bir senede iki buçuk milyon
insana ulaşmaya başladı ve aylık 75
milyon izleme sahibim şu an ve tarifleri
mis toplumun büyük kısmı görebilir
neredeyse Bu benim için çok büyük bir
başarı bıç ok istediğim bir şehri
ailem o meslek tercihini yani o en büyük
tercihimi yapmam gerektiği gün ailem ne
yapmak istiyorsan onu yapmamı söylemişti
ve ben işimde en iyisi olmak istiyorum
şu Martin Luther King'in bir sözü var
Ben bunu birazcık değiştirdim
eğer biri sizden size bir kürdan verip
mutfağın her yerini temizlemesini
istiyorsa umutlu o kadar iyi temizliğin
ki yerdeki ve Gökteki herkes bakıp bu
burada işini gerçekten çok iyi yapan
dünyanın belki de en iyi sesi var
desinler Bu benim için bir mod duydu
hayatım boyunca bunun üzerinden
ilerlemek istedim Bir sonraki hedefim de
Global düzeyde işimi gerçekten çok iyi
yapıp yerdeki ve Gökteki herkesin bana
bakıp burada için çok iyi yapan Belki de
dünyanın en iyi içerik üreticisi sesi
var demeleri
kariyeri boyunca hep küçük küçük
adımları attığım küçük küçük adımlar
Benim büyük adımı oluşturduğu bu sizde
adımlarınızı atarken karşınıza çıkan
hiçbir zorluktan vazgeçmeyin Çünkü
başarmak istiyorsanız vazgeçmelisiniz
Yok teşekkür ederim Çok sağ ol oğlum